（サンシャイン池崎 風に）…
…はじめしゃちょーです。
皆さま…
僕も生えてますよ。
ちょび… ああ なん…ケガしてんじゃん。
ちょび ちょび っと生えてるんですけど。
僕ですね レーザー脱毛に⇒
いった事がありまして。
僕 そんな メチャクチャ体毛が濃い訳でもないんですけども⇒
試しに レーザー脱毛に行ったんですよ。…
女性のかたでよく レーザー脱毛をする人はいると思うんですけども⇒
あぁ… 男 諸君。かなり… 気合いが要るぞ。
男のヒゲとかは 多分 濃いから⇒
多分 全然 女の人より痛いと思うんですけど。
ヤバイっスよ。レーザー脱毛は ホントに。
麻酔 打たないと耐えれないぐらいの痛みなんですけども。…
（指パッチン）
という訳で 多分 男も女もね⇒
体の毛という物を気にする人がいると思うんですけども⇒
今回 こういう物を見つけました。
『光エステ』。
はい これは なにやらですね⇒
光を使ってね 脱毛をする なにかでございます。
光を当てて なんか 脱毛してくヤツらしいんですけども。
これ なんか ここにもある通りですね⇒
肌の色が 結構 カギになってまして。
濃いお肌には 対応してないんですよ。
これ なぜかと言いますと⇒
レーザー脱毛も同じなんですけども⇒
あの 脱毛っていうのはですね⇒
黒い物に反応して⇒
その黒い物にレーザーを照射して⇒
焼き殺すんだと思います。…
信じないで下さいね。分かんないんですけど⇒
多分 おおよそそんな感じじゃないかなと思います。
これも多分 同様に⇒
肌は 毛と比べて白いじゃないですか。
肌を傷めずに 黒い この 毛の部分だけ⇒
バチン バチン バチン って光を当てて⇒
ぶっ殺していくっていうのが レーザー脱毛なんですよ。
いや ホントね レーザー脱毛ね 一回 体験してほしい。
もう なんか けいれん 起こしながら やってたらしいです 僕は。
うわ す… うわ これ ヤバイな ガチだな。
うわ すご… プリズム。プリズム。スペクトグラムって感じですね。
いや あの なんかね レーザー脱毛の痛みはね⇒
あの 言葉で表すと⇒
説明は スゴイ… 輪ゴムで軽く弾かれる程度です⇒
みたいな感じなんですけど 実際は なんだろうな⇒
1000度に熱した 書き初めの紙を 留める あの⇒
ぶんちんの部分で ここを 一瞬⇒
ジュッ てされるみたいな感じです。…
ん〜 もう ホント 痛かったからねぇ。
どうしても 毛が気になるって人はオススメします。
マジで 一切生えて来なくなるんで。
僕は途中で脱走したんで まだちょっと生えてます。
これで… 電源 オン。
（機械の動作音）
もう始まってる？ え 怖い 怖い 怖い。
なんか 目とか… 目とか隠さなくていいの？
ひとまず 毛をそるらしいですね。
腕の毛をそって。
で ここに 多分 光を当ててくんだと思いますけど⇒
なにも分かりません。
（「カチッ」）
（「ピッ」）
アヴラアアアァァーーーーーーーーー!!!
イエェェェェーーーーーーー!!!
なに なに？
（ファンの動作音のような機械音）
変な音が鳴ってる。
もう始まってる？
（「ピッ」）
うっ…。アアッ!! アッ！ 目が!! 目が!!
イエェェェェーーーーーーー!!!
いや… 目が… スゴイ。目がヤバかった 今。
（「ピッ」）
ウッ アッ… 熱い!!! 熱い!!! 熱い!!! あつ… アッ アッ！
イエェーーイ！
なるほど。う… 痛いわ これ！
待って。ヤバイ。思い出す。
レーザー脱毛の痛みを。
アッ ア… 熱い!!
あ… 痛い！
熱い!!
イッタ…。
あ でも 弱いっスね。痛い！ ではあっすっし…。
あっ まあ まあ まあ まあ まあ… こんなもんか。
あのですね これ あのー 多分⇒
出力… アツッ！
出力的には 多分 その⇒
レーザ… アツッ！
レーザー脱毛の… アツッ！
弱めの出力で設定してあるんで⇒
そんな… アツッ！ アッ 病院でやる方が⇒
多分 全然 痛いので こっちは多分⇒
皆さん!! でも耐えれるほうだと思います。
これよりも!! もっと痛いのが その 病院で受ける実際の⇒
レーザー!! 脱毛なんです。
市販でも出来る脱毛器具っていうのが⇒
最近 色々 あるんですけども。
ま 最初に説明した通り⇒
これは 黒い物に反応します。
なんで まあ 多分 僕の服にこうやって バチンってやったら…
今回 この性能を生かしてですね⇒
黒い部分が多くなった⇒
バナナをね 脱毛してみようと思います。
黒い部分が出て来てる シュガースポットのトコですね。
バナナっていうのは まあ 毛が生えてませんし⇒
かと言って 中には 繊維が詰まっています。
黒い部分とかに反応して⇒
光を当てて脱毛すると 果たしてバナナはどうなるのか。
熱かったらね ひょっとしたらホットバナナになって⇒
あの… おいしくなるかもしれません。
じゃあ 早速 ちょっと バナナを脱毛してみようと思います。
なんでこんな事 思い付いたんだろう？
純粋にですね…⇒
どうなるのかなって思いました。
黒いトコにしか反応しませんからね。
バナナ 脱毛しまーす。
（「ピピッ。ピッ」）
なにが起きてる？
特になにも… ちょっと 何回かやってみますか。
はい という訳で 何回かやってみたんですけども⇒
コゲクサい感じはする。
果たして中身はどうなってるのでしょうか？
あけていきましょう！
あぁ あぁぁ！
なんにも 変化がありませんでした。
イエェーーー!!!
♪♪〜
皮は 多分ね ちょっと 傷んだ気がします。
多分 バナナ自体は白いから 反応しなかったんですけども⇒
バナナの皮は黒かったから 反応したみたいでございます。
病院とか 出力の強いヤツだったら⇒
ホントに マジで 超 痛いです。
これも 痛かったですからね。
バナナは脱毛しても この 周りが守ってくれるので⇒
味は落ちる事がありませんでした。
よかったですね。 という訳で みなさん⇒
レーザー脱毛はホントに痛いので⇒
行くかたはぜひ 覚悟していってみて下さい。
じゃあな！
ア!!